ah
I know I know
uthman right stop it
[Music]
for those of you who do not know I
recently had a run-in with Sheikh
uthmond and sneako at Balboa Park okay
so if that's
if that's a change let's see if I say
you sat at the table versus I sat at the
table is that the same thing in
different languages they mean different
things oh thank you so it doesn't mean
the same thing and if you want to see
that full discussion you can just click
this link above and the link will also
be down in the description below of this
video it was really fun we had a great
time but this was something that was
interesting we walked up to the tent to
uthman's Booth after a kid had told us
that uthman and sneaker were down there
we walk up down there and uthman and the
rest of the crew looks so uncomfortable
when they see us and I'm trying to
figure out why would they be so
uncomfortable seeing us I mean uh Islam
is is this you know strong religion it's
based on truth and really grounded and
Allah is Akbar he's bigger greater or a
mouse or whatever the word means right
anyway he's so this religion is is
confident it's undefeated so why is it
that uthman and the rest of his uh the
rest of his party looks so nervous when
we walk up and don't want to have the
conversation I mean they're really
desperate to not have this conversation
watch
[Music]
we're out here we're not gonna come out
right you can't see it
[Music]
I mean they're literally using their
pamphlets to block the angle of the
camera so that the camera can't see
they're trying to stand on top of chairs
to block the visual of the camera
they're trying to move and nudge Anthony
and I guess keep them off balance so
that we can't record I mean Anthony has
to hold up the tripod like this in order
to for the camera to get a view this is
why we have the angle that we did
because they were really trying to stop
us from recording and I'm like why would
they want this like we're here for a
conversation the the sign on your booth
literally says ask a Muslim right it
says Jesus is a Muslim so this is
inviting us to come and talk to the
Muslims I guess unless you know what
you're talking about and have any
inclination of what Islam teaches you're
not allowed it was a fun time I had a
great time with uthman and snico but
here's something here's something great
I was called a liar
surprisingly right I was called a liar I
was accused of bringing an NIV Bible the
first time that I met uthman he's
bringing objections when it comes to the
age of ahaziah was he 22 was he 42 right
and so he says that I brought an NIV
Bible the first time uh to answer the
objections that he was Raising against
me the first time take a look so now
it's my turn so it's my turn
no I never did it I've never done video
in your video I want you to pull up the
I want you to pull up the clip before I
brought it and I said let me finish okay
where I said the NIV is the best version
right right look look no I never said
that no first of all we find a clip from
you
again
what do you want then what do you want
then admit that you like I will now when
you can't find the clip will you admit
that you lied sure on camera on your
channel on my channel
Okay cool so first of all I never ever
brought an NIV Bible to him never in my
life I don't even use an NIV Bible there
I don't have possession of a single NIV
Bible at home in my car nowhere right I
I don't like the nib Bible actually it's
the called in my circle the non-inspired
version we don't I I don't I can I don't
care for the NIV what I brought to him
was an ESV Study Bible so he said that I
said out of my own mouth that the NIV is
the best translation and that I brought
it using it to answer his objections
when that never happened
so here's the evidence that he brought
he brought the clip let's see if I said
anything that he accused me of now you
will see the same man that came to our
stall two years ago on video and when I
showed him the new King James version
the same Bible that I used today and I
showed him clear contradictions in the
ages at that time he will bring out the
NIV version he will bring out the NIV
version the ni view he will not say that
they ruled at different ages he will
bring out the NIV version and he will
praise it saying that it is based on
earlier manuscripts then the new King
James Version
yeah
okay okay read it Jehovah chin was 18
years old when he became excellent
no what what chapter and verse is this
second chronicles 36 was enough read it
here
joking was eight years old okay so why
is it that that Bible has 18 and this
has eight yeah
this is the King James version
the yours is based on certain
manuscripts that came so which one is
the actual Bible Well we have we have
the earliest manuscript that helps us
okay so that's why so this Bible is
based on an error how the liar is
exposed he himself brought the McCarthy
Study Bible praised it dependent on it
used it to answer contradictions and
then when the McCarthy Study Bible says
that there are clear copyist errors he
throws it under the bus notice how on
his screen there is a King James version
being compared to an NIV version why the
NIV wasn't even spoken of did you guys
hear me say anything about the NIV I
mean you guys can go back and watch the
entire video no not a single second of
that video has me mentioning the NIV so
he died right there I never said the nib
was the best version as a matter of fact
if you see if you take a close look
the Bible that I was using
it has a it has a black cover on the top
with a white strip in the middle and
it's like an ocean blue at the bottom
that is the Bible that I brought it is
an ESV John MacArthur Study Bible it was
my carry around Bible that I took with
me everywhere but with I misplaced it or
otherwise I'll be able to show it but I
found the link that shows the exact
Bible that I had and I know it's a
little blurry but if you take a close
look at it at the words it says English
Standard Version that's the Bible that I
brought to uthman in ESV Study Bible by
John McArthur not an NIV Bible
so this is where we're at now uthman if
you are a man of your words if you have
any type of decency any type of
Integrity I know that you're a habitual
liar I know that you literally have to
lie lie lie and save face and divert and
play victim this is what you have to do
you have to come on your video on your
channel like you said you would and you
have to admit that you lied and you put
words in my mouth and you did so to
divert the conversation because you
couldn't deal with my actual argument so
this is what the onus is now on you
matter of fact scratch that I don't I
don't that's not even good enough for me
anymore so not only do you have to admit
that you lied uthman but what I want you
to do for us is raise up your little
dress and show us the wound so do his
blood bath
show us the Stab Wound of that
islamophobe that came and attacked you
that's all I want that's all I want you
ain't got to do much I just want to see
the wound on camera where you can show
that you've been stabbed is that too
much to ask so I admit that you lied
like you said you would and then show us
the wound and then you'll probably be in
my good graces you have 48 hours to
respond now on top of that he was trying
to make the argument that textual
variance in the Bible proves that the
Bible is unreliable proves that the
Bible is false in some way here's
something to note we as Christians
acknowledge that we have textual
variants we don't make the same claim
that the Muslims claim for example
Muslims claim that the Quran is verbatim
the words of Allah the word of God every
single word is the word of God had no uh
man dealings with it at all right it's
the word of God verbatim we Christians
don't believe that about the the the
Bible we Christians claim that Jesus is
the word of God he's the word of God the
revealer of God while the Bible is his
inspired word that he used man to write
down right and so there are textual
variants within the manuscripts that
have no effect on Christian theology
there's not a single variant in any of
the manuscripts that contradict the
Theology of Christianity we don't have a
problem with textual variants we don't
make the claim that the Bible has been
preserved in the sense that every single
word and letter has been has never been
changed or there's no difference isn't
that no the word of God has been
preserved in the sense that its meaning
has been preserved right its theology
has been preserved the message is
preserved that's what Christians believe
but that's not what Muslims believe
which is why they actually have an issue
because of textual variance proves that
a book is unreliable
then you just left Islam uthman I raised
up the argument
that there's a textual variant in
chapter 37 verse 12 where Allah says to
Muhammad in the Huff's Quran
you were surprised when they mocked
while in the caliph Quran it's I was
surprised II
I was surprised when they mocked which
one is it now with man said that I was
saying the word wrong I didn't know what
I was talking about it's not objecta
there's no TA or no or two it's right
it's ajibat
now so I asked some Muslims who speak
the language and
I wanted to get their opinion on it are
you able to read this MD or resign
anybody yes
did you hear that say it one more time
and say it loud and clear
Bell what what
oh yes
okay beautiful when we read the single
verse it's a but you say it's right when
you read a single word it is
so according to the Muslims who know the
language I the non-arabic speaking
Christian was correct
I was saying it right that it's Ajit
with a TA at the end it's
not whatever the Sheikh was saying so
how is it that these Muslims who speak
the language and this
non-arabic-speaking Christian know what
they're talking about in the shake the
one who has the Masters in Hadith he
doesn't know the word that he's reading
he can't even read it off the page we
see that he already is out of his depth
and he was so nervous here this is such
a big issue that even their Scholars
talk about this and I quoted akur to be
that talks about the differences that
they had and how a certain group was
reading uh it one way while another
group was reading it another and how one
group rejected the other reading right
and so he tried to bring evidence for my
court to be that says that there is no
difference in the meaning that the
meaning is the same and it goes back to
Muhammad listen they continuously quote
El cortabi a book that this man is
unable to read he does not own he has
never looked at the actual book he just
has some islamophobes that feed him this
information
actually says he quotes at the end of a
long discussion that Ali Suleiman
mentioned that the meaning in both of
the styles of recitation is the same is
the same is the same meaning it does not
affect the meaning because even when you
have a two it's takdir meaning that it's
meaning
and the TA is also or Muhammad so those
are two ways of saying the same thing
from the same Quran written the same way
in the musafman
which all go back to the same meaning
that it is the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him who's amazed not Allah now of
course I'm an islamophobe I can't read
the language I don't know what I'm
talking about
so I phoned in a friend who is a native
Arabic speaker and I wanted to get
his thoughts on the matter this is this
is the screens and I'm happy that you
used it brother in your video uh
brother nobody here is best in the end
we're all Sinners and
we're on one team brother there's no
difference between you and me uh we're
all Sinners and if we can help one
another build one another for the glory
of Christ then so be it brother so 37-12
this is the house version right
and Avery what does it says
that's what he said right yeah
I can't even read the Arabic yeah
and the in context is about Muhammad
because Allah is talking to Muhammad you
Muhammad you wonder while they mock
that's what the half says I mean you
don't need to be a genius uh only if you
only have basic Arabic language skills
you'll see that someone is talking to
someone you in this case you
you wonder you are shocked while the
enemies mock you or they mock your
religion whatever so Allah is talking to
Muhammad
if we go to the other versions
for short it says
talking about himself so Allah is the
one talking about himself
that he is the one who is shocked who is
wondering while the enemies mock so is
it Muhammad is Allah talking to Muhammad
or is Allah talking about himself and
how can Allah be shocked brother Avery
oh that's a great question he's supposed
to be all-knowing isn't he yeah and it's
not only the fella version many versions
actually I counted them all that I had
found the exactly six of different
variations that contradict the house six
of them on nquran.com That's So the
website that I love to use here is the
Khalif let us go to another one
that's the the full reading name of the
full reading it says again but I Allah
Wonder while they mock a Jeep 2 versus
the hubs Ajit
now as you see here I put a small
comment underneath do you see it brother
yes this says this was the reading of
IBN Abbas IBN Abbas shows Egypt too he
didn't choose the hubs as the hubs says
it so should we go by even Abbas or by
even ketchup what do you think well I
think Eben ketchup is a little bit uh
he's the new ink of the Uma hey uh he's
the new new
scholarsi guys he just throw Urban Abbas
under the bus and he chose another
opinion that also can be found in tafsir
alcorto but if you see her Eben Abbas
actually chose the one with
the one with
the dhamma with the o a 2 that's
what the Arabic says here
so that's called that's called the Duma
right that's called
so the house version has a feta
you
right the dhamma the thing that looks
like a a nine let's say yeah as you see
here on top the nine if I make it a
little bit bigger look it looks like a
small tiny wow uh oh nine whatever you
want to call it a nine let's say it's me
it makes it all the Arab right oh you so
the grammar changes the meaning changes
and this was the reading how IBN Abbas
used to read it exactly why didn't he
included that part in his video boom
boom
so you mean to tell me that he was he
was picking and choosing and found
wonderful opinion that he could hold on
to and say see these are the same yeah
he went here on the page brother because
this is
the hubs version supposedly
this one does not agree with IBN Abbas
as I showed you IBN Abbas was reading it
with a dhamma and here there's a guy
even saying I am choosing the Kira of
Ali
um
by the way that's among the four guys
remember I said
so Ali is reading abdullah's reading and
even our best reading was ajib
two boom boom
you see how he's cherry picking brother
and let's just now go to Muhammad
himself what do you think brother let's
do it let's go through himself look the
prophet you can read it brother go ahead
this is
3010 read it narrated Abu Herrera the
prophet said Allah wonders at those
people who will enter Paradise in Chains
Allah does what he wonders done
yo what I mean I mean yeah that's good
stuff right there it says literally who
[Music]
is explaining it as Allah is the one
doing the Wonders Allah is the one is
wondering Allah is shocked so you see
why even Abbas agrees with his Prophet
wait so all our wonders so you have in
sahiha bukhari Muhammad saying that
Allah wonders so Muhammad and Iman Abbas
said that Allah wonders so why is Sheikh
uthman going against Muhammad and going
against IBN Abbas
who is the ink of the Uma who has the
wisdom of the Quran this is who IBN
Abbas is so uthman selectively
cherry-picked a section of an opinion of
someone to make it seem like he was
correct and justified in his in what he
was saying but if you read the entire
tough Seer and if he reads what IBN
Abbas said and what the other said ajip
2 goes to Allah why are you lying man
you're caught again now sorry the title
right about the title about the title
uthman was right what was he right about
this is what he was right about this is
whether ignorance gets caught where
they're ignorant gets caught oh
my God logic
[Music]